[Music]
good morning and welcome to trevor
phillips on sunday
they call new york the city that never
sleeps well for the last 24 hours at
least it's been hard to tear your eyes
away from the drama in the big apple
yesterday morning the city woke to a
somber remembrance 20 years on from the
tragedy of 9 11 led by presidents biden
obama and clinton
and last night if they did get to bed
they would have been marveling at the
titanic tennis final between two players
neither of whom was yet born on that day
and
say so perhaps reflecting not just
by
emma radekanu and layla fernandez
brilliance on the court but if anyone
saw their after match interviews they
would have been struck by the
graciousness and poise of both young
women
boris johnson's been known to wield a
racket from time to time he finally
served up his social care proposals this
week along with a tax rise and a benefit
cut
next week he's promising a volley of new
ideas on how we're going to manage
covert through the winter
we're going to see what our guests make
of it did he smash it or is it all spin
enough with the tennis already
joining us today from the government
i'll be speaking to the health secretary
sajid javid
scotland's first minister nicholas
sturgeon will be here
snp give it one more push for indie ref
2 at their party conference this weekend
the shadow health secretary jonathan
ashworth will be joining me to talk
about a huge week for public health
spending
and i'll also be talking to former
foreign secretary jack straw about the
lessons learned from 9 11
20 years on
first i'm joined by health secretary
sajid
javid
mr javid good morning did you
see the match last night
i saw most of it and i've got to say
just like the rest of the country i was
just absolutely
thrilled to see what emma had done i
mean what what a phenomenal uh
performance but what also you're just a
huge inspiration to all of us
wasn't it um extraordinary not to extend
this the
i thought i thought the eloquence of the
two young women afterwards and their
their graciousness to each other to each
other should be a lesson to politics
shouldn't it
it's a lesson to us all i mean to to go
through that and both with the that
desire to win but whatever the result
how they sort of come together they
embrace each other afterwards i think
there's lessons there for all of us
all right well let's um let's talk about
the uh hostilities um
open this morning with uh an
investigation by a newspaper into your
colleague pretty patel who it is alleged
has broken the lobbying rules again
is she becoming
a liability to your government
no not at all i mean i i've done that
job her being home secretary i know just
how
difficult a job it is and i think she's
been doing really well over the last
couple of years and it's it certainly is
one of the most challenging jobs in
government and uh i remember when i had
that job when you're waking up almost
every day and finding there's something
going on that you know is something to
do with the home office and it's it's a
big job and i think she's doing a good
job
yeah but um she could probably do
without not to extend the tennis
metaphor too much without yet more
unforced errors by meeting people she
ordered to be meeting no i i haven't
seen that report said i'm not sure what
you're referring to but
i i think that as i say it's a it's a
really tough job and she's doing really
well there's so many things that she's
already done with the legislation that's
been put forward but i also know as home
secretary you also do a huge amount that
never gets into the public car because
it's not something you can ever talk
about publicly and
and i think it's obvious to me having
done that job that she's carrying out
that part of the work here the stuff
that's never in the public you know
incredibly well
okay let's talk about how you're doing
your job can we please expect that there
will be no need for pcr tests when we
travel in the near future
well
trevor if i may just uh sort of set out
our plans uh for the future and i will
respond to that question as well you
know that we're entering autumn and
winter it's something that covered other
viruses you know usually like the prime
minister this week will be setting out
our plans to manage covid over the
coming few months and in that we'll be
making it clear that first of all our
vaccine program is working it's been
phenomenally successful we now got uh
over 80 percent of people over the age
of 16 you're double vaccinated some 90
percent at least uh having one jab and
it's been fantastic in reducing the rate
of hospitalization you're something we
all wanted to see alongside that where
it's been complemented by your fantastic
new treatments a juggernaut of a testing
regime and uh also our surveillance
program probably the one of the best in
the world so you know we've got a huge
number of defenses of course we still
want to remain very cautious and there
are some things that when it comes to
travel for example there are some rules
that are going to have to remain in
place but the pcr
test that's required upon your return to
uk from certain countries look i want to
try and get rid of that as soon as i
possibly can i'm not going to make that
decision uh right now but i've already
asked officials that the moment we can
let's get rid of these kind of
intrusions the cost that generates for
families particularly families just
trying to go out on holiday you know we
shouldn't be keeping anything like that
in place for a second longer than is
absolutely necessary okay so um the uh
pcr tests gone asap what about vaccines
for 12 to 15 year olds also asap
well
i think your your viewers will know that
we have been looking at that i'm not in
a position to make a final decision on
it i've received advice a week or so ago
from the jcvi our committee of experts
their advice uh was that
that i should ask the these chief
medical officers of the uk the four
chief officers in the uk to to take a
look at not just the the health aspects
of vaccination but whether there were
any broader reasons that it might be in
the welfare of children and that's what
i've done and they need to be given the
time to look at this and i'll wait to
see what they have to say have they
given when will they give you their
advice
i'm not gonna push they need to take
their time it's a it's independent
advice as it as it should be they need
to take their time i don't think they'll
be taking uh you know that much longer
um but in the meantime i have asked the
department to work with schools the
school vaccination teams to start
preparing you know just in case uh we
have a situation where their advice is
to recommend it and that if that if the
government accepts that then i just want
to be able to go ahead with it
isn't this a little bit um of a relaxed
approach to something that is really
rather urgent we're already seeing cases
spiking in scotland uh after schools
opened there a few weeks ago and
actually
you're saying that we're focusing on the
vaccine you said that this morning as a
first line of defense but actually we're
seeing warning signs from elsewhere in
the world israel for example that the
effectiveness of the vaccine
might be waning are you being a bit
complacent about the situation
no not at all i think that just let's
deal with um
the vaccinations there both potentially
for children but also potentially
boosters and i'll come on to that the
for vaccinating children if we are to
make such a decision
it has to be led by the experts we have
to listen to expert opinion now as i've
said the jcvi have already looked at
this they made a recommendation to me to
pass it
to have another look from a different
aspect from other medical experts and
that's the right way to do it and i
think it's fair to say that you know
people adults are going to be naturally
more hesitant about vaccinating their
children and they worry about
vaccinating themselves that's perfectly
understandable that's true the world
over so if we're going to do this it has
to be done properly and it must not be
rushed when it can be done soon
well
hopefully soon and as i say
in anticipation of uh the final advice
you know i want to be ready and that's
why the system is getting ready for this
but can i also just turn to boosters
because you talked about waning immunity
we now of course do know more about this
virus and vaccination than we ever knew
before there is evidence of waning
immunity particularly in in older people
more vulnerable people and we're already
taking action on that so for example
just a week ago i announced that those
people that are immuno suppressed you
know that they that should get a third
uh jab you know as part of their primary
treatment that has already started and
in terms of a general booster program we
have asked the jcvi to look into this
they gave me interim advice a month or
so ago where they supported this but
they said they wanted to do some further
work we give them the time to do that
work but i believe we will be able to
start our booster program subject to
their final advice on schedule this
month
good okay now um
when the prime minister speaks to us
this week about
his program for the autumn and winter
will that include vaccine passports of
the kind that the scots have already
decided they will have that is to say
when i go clubbing will i need to have a
vaccine passport
well trevor i know you like clubbing i
know why this is so
important to you so
let me answer your question then look i
think if we went down the road of
vaccine passports or vaccine
certification as it's sometimes called
that's a big decision for any government
to make we have been looking at that
we've been open about that instinctively
you know i don't like the idea at all of
people having to let's say present
papers uh to do you know basic things so
if we do that the there it has to be
something uh that is looked at very
carefully and something that we believe
that has to be done with no alternative
with the vaccination rates with the
vaccination rates uh rising for example
with 16 and 17 year olds we only started
uh just last month now over 50 percent
of 16 70 year olds are already uh
vaccinated you know i think we need to
take that into account and make a final
decision but i hope we can avoid it
well you say you hope you can avoid it
but
this is a precautionary issue i mean
uh
vaccine passports
uh are proposed because uh they need we
need to protect uh people well coming
back to the clubs people like myself and
michael globe uh gov who are in and out
of clubs every week we need to protect
people
are you ruling it out or is it still on
the table
look i am not i'm not here today to to
rule that out we haven't made a final
decision at as a government we have been
looking at it we've been very open about
that but i as i've said that i think if
we did something like that it has to be
supported by the evidence and uh it has
to be something that is absolutely
absolutely necessary with no alternative
so you know as i say i hope we can avoid
it
what is the evidence telling you about
the big danger this winter is it
more covered delta variant is it a new
variant or is it conventional flu what
is the evidence telling you that we need
to be most concerned about
well
winter autumn
it's not just covid that likes that part
of the year it's other viruses too and
you've just mentioned another really
important uh thing that we've got to
prepare for and that is flu i've already
mentioned the the preparations for
boosters and i think that's going to be
an important part of our defense but
when it comes to flu what we've been
planning in the past few weeks is the
biggest flu vaccination program this
country has ever seen why am i concerned
about that because last year we didn't
have much flu because of all the other
controls that were in place and that
means just is a lot less immunity around
to flu than than normal and we know that
in some years in a bad flu year just how
terrible it can be so alongside our
continuing
covert vaccine program we're going to
have our biggest ever flu program and i
would say to those people listening that
certainly those are over 50 getting your
flu jab is going to be as important as
having your cover jab all right let's
talk about the other big announcement of
last week when you broke your manifesto
pledge in order to introduce a new
health and social care levy a new tax
um you've asked us to believe that the
12 million billion
that you're going to raise each year for
the next three years will eventually go
into social care um when you're in
banking would you say to a customer i've
just raised the interest rate on your
loan but don't worry trust me uh would
you uh give me your mortgage to look
after
why would we trust
what you say
after you've broken not one but two
manifesto pledges
well first can i just turn to the
manifesto pledges since you started uh
with that you're right we made we made a
commitment that we wouldn't raise
certain taxes and that included uh
national insurance now we had an option
given the global pandemic we had an
option we could doggedly sort of stick
to that manifesto commitment and say
look you know what we know there's a
global pandemic we know that there's
unprecedented strain on our health and
social care systems they need more
support but we're going to ignore that
because we've got a manifesto commitment
or we could have said we're going to do
the responsible thing and the
circumstances have changed and i think
it's no exaggeration to say that no one
had predicted this this pandemic and
that it has changed you know so many
things and we could respond to that in a
responsible way and that's what we've
done and
i wasn't prepared to see as the health
secretary for example with the nhs with
the growth that we were seeing in the
waiting list i wasn't prepared to see
that waiting has been any higher than it
needs to be i want that waiting list to
be tackled and the way to do it is to
make sure that the resources are there
and they're also making the right
reforms aha now look that's a great
justification but you could be if you're
still health secretary a year from now
and you might want to tell me something
about the reshuffle speculation if you
want you could be coming on here next
year and giving me another great and
smooth reason for why you've changed
your mind let me ask you if you would
give us a commitment you're saying that
you're switching the money into social
care when uh the covered emergency
allows and waiting lists allow you to
get to somewhere set a level
is that is that going to happen when uh
waiting lists get back to pre-covered
level let's say for example the level of
2010 when tories came into government of
2.5 million uh would you would you say
that's when social care gets the money
now what i'll say trevor is that you
first of all of the the announcement the
money that we said that will be raised
the total and you're 36 billion you know
some 5.4 billion of that will be going
to social care no matter what happens
that's going to be going into social
care to support the new cap to support a
more generous means-tested system to
give local councils more support more
workplace training so that's going to go
into social care over time over the sort
of those three years the the the nhs
would have made your maximum use huge
use in in tackling the waiting list uh
with uh the money that it will be
getting but also
that cap that we've announced the 86 000
pound cap on lifetime costs that only
sort of starts the bite in later years
you're beyond the three years and that's
why this levy i'm certain will be able
to cover that cost and those costs in in
the years you know beyond the next uh
you know parliamentary period there's a
timing thing here though let me tell you
what they're saying in local government
they're saying that
when you start spending the money on
social care which is 2023
the money that you've raised from this
new tax will still be going into the nhs
and you know who's going to have to fill
the gap in those three years local
government
through raising the council tax and what
you will then do is say
we raise the tax but local government
spendthrift they're not doing their part
you are going to dump this on local
councils aren't you
no not at all i mean already today
spending on adult social care some in
normal times around 20 billion pounds a
year that's a combination of funding
from central government and locally
raised funds what we've announced this
week is a top-up on that to to provide
as i say the more workplace training
this new system of a cabin and better
means testing so it's a top-up of that
it will remain a combination of funds
and and each year it will be determined
uh based on need but the the changes
that we've announced today will make it
a stronger system and and local
authorities will continue to play a
hugely important role in that
okay look um a quick question on
universal credit and you can do this on
in yes and no
are you going to cut universal credit by
20 pounds a week
we're we're going to end the temporary
increase in universal credit
so the answer yes that cut you're not
budging on that at all
the the the the the increase which was
temporary will be ended as planned at
the end of this month
it's been reported this weekend that the
prime minister reckons that he wants to
stay in downing street for another
decade um well obviously the
electorate's going to decide that but
they're going to want to know
why he wants to stay there and there's a
curious thing here you spend trillions
of public money
you intrude on individual freedom down
to telling us what we can and cannot
wear on our faces and you boast about
defending the most socialist health
system in europe um what exactly is
conservative about the tories right now
well if you look at you talked about the
intrusion of freedom and that you're
right to raise that we should never
intrude on people's freedom
unless there was a really really good
reason to do so what we've seen in the
last couple years is the government
respond to a global
emergency respond with the most
successful vaccination program the world
has ever seen
and
and help us get through this very
difficult period including having to
break a manifesto promise to make sure
that we show people just how responsible
and serious this government is about
meeting the people's challenges we've
done that even the the package we've
talked about we've done that in a
responsible way by by being honest and
raising attacks instead of borrowing and
mortgaging the future of the next
generation that's very conservative too
but we are always looking to to make
sure that as a country that we support
businesses we support the economy so it
can continue to grow and there's there's
no doubt as we start to see that growth
now we can create the opportunities that
everyone would expect a conservative
government to do so all right well look
let me let me ask you a question
uh which essentially uh is about whether
you don't come back on here and give me
some more reasons for why you're not
really a tory will you commit to no more
tax rises in this parliament
look i'm not chancellor anymore
if you get the chance on your show you
can ask him about tax questions what i
can tell you as a conservative and as a
proud member of a conservative
government you know we should always be
trying to keep taxes as low as we
possibly can and and making sure that we
recognize that when you have tax any
type of tax you're taking away hard
working people's money and every single
penny should be spent wisely all right
let me put this another way then
deal between you
sajid javid and me trevor phillips
if somebody comes forward chancellor
prime minister with a proposal for more
tax rises in this parliament will you
sergeant javid oppose those tax rises
i think we should be if we have to spend
more somewhere else i think that we
should always be trying first to see
where we can make savings to to pay for
that not extra tax rises and tax rise
should always be the last resort it's
been right to do it on this occasion but
we should always uh try to avoid it
last resort for uh tax risers thank you
very much
thank you very much
now what happened in new york and
washington 20 years ago changed the
world
two decades on the west is still
fighting a war against islamist terror
or is it it's still not clear whether
the american withdrawal from kabul is
simply fulfilling a promise or whether
it herald the end of an era of liberal
interventionism
my next guest
jack straw was foreign secretary in tony
blair's government when the attacks took
place
he joins me now from oxfordshire
jack straw um
yesterday must have brought back some
vivid memories of that day in 2001. what
stood out for you personally
yesterday or in 2001.
well when you think back to 2001 what
stands out i mean it was it what stands
out it took simply
the way that everything changed in an
instant
the period
really between
the collapse of the berlin wall and
after things had stabilized and
certainly
the relative stabilization in the
balkans
and september the 10th 2001 would have
been a pretty calm one uh
internationally
so nothing not a huge amount was going
on
suddenly all that changed
and
particularly for the americans because
they
had become very used over decades and
decades
to seeing their mainland territory as
completely invaluable
to foreign enemies
indeed there'd be no attack on the us
mainland since the british
navy and marines attacked washington dc
and burnt the white house but that was
in 1812 so it really was a really deep
trauma
and that led
to
the atmosphere in which the decisions
were made not only uh in respect of
uh the invasion of afghanistan but
subsequently in respect of
iran
sorry
i want you to ask on that day
did you
fear
that london would also be a target
at that time
for sure yes of course um and
uh
i don't even remember but
air traffic was closed down we were
really very worried indeed because these
guys had the capability
to
hijack four
passenger planes and have trained pilots
to run into the world trade center
uh the uh pentagon uh and what they're
hoping was either the white house or
uh capitol hill they could easily done
that in london but for example taking
that canary wharf
and the whole of the palace of
westminster house of commons
so we were extremely worried about it
indeed
um i mean
yeah
let's let's talk let's talk about what's
happened since and obviously
the most
present issue is afghanistan it's
obviously early days there
but do you believe the taliban when they
say that they're going to be different
this time
well i think they'll be a bit different
uh
because
in the last 20 years
um
the majority the vast majority of people
in afghanistan particularly women
but very many men as well have learned
to enjoy
their freedoms
and
they're going to be resisting having
those taken away
also
the country is far more reliant on the
west than ever it was i mean just for
example there were virtually no mobile
telephones there 20 years ago
everybody's going to go on a mobile
telephone now and that requires a
reliance on overseas technical
technology
they'll also be under pressure not only
from the west but also from russia and
china although russia and china
want to
make a point against the west
they are also
petrified about islamic islamic
extremism in their own countries as well
as in neighbouring afghanistan so they
will be under greater pressure
but the question is have they feel like
change their spots i mean my instinct is
they haven't so they'll be
that their instinct
will be to do what they did before a key
to how they behave
is the attitude of pakistan and it's not
often sufficiently discussed this
but just bear in mind that the
intelligence inter-services intelligence
directorate of pakistan
part of their their defense operation
has been
up to its neck in ventriloquising
and supporting the taliban over decades
so their attitude matters as well
what would you what would you do about
pakistan then i mean
what how can the west use its influence
in this respect uh with difficulty but
but i mean partly listen to them and
take their advice i mean
because after
the reason they have this extraordinary
ambiguous relationship
with the
uh taliban and with other extremists on
their north west frontier is be is is
not necessarily because the the very
modern people in lahore in islamabad and
karachi
support them but they're scared of them
and it's about how you as it were tame
this tiger so listen to them i mean one
of the mistakes we did make which i now
recognize would very few of us saw at
the time
uh back in 2001 was in having no
political route out of its defeat for
the taliban
and for those forces who supported them
and coupled with that
we decided to conflate counter-terrorist
strategy which is absolutely right with
the counter-narcotic strategy which
frankly was a bridge too far which is
taking away the livelihood of uh people
whilst you were also trying to get them
on site on counter-terrorism
and
so we need to learn from those lessons
also be tough with them
briefly if i may um
is the biggest lesson that we should
learn from this
that uh our approach to tackling
islamist terror
has failed
and they've won because we focused on
the military
when perhaps we need to to do more to
focus on what i think tony blair this
week described as the ideology winning
hearts and minds to the idea that
the west way of life democracy and so on
is better than the alternative offered
by islamists
the i mean i don't think it's that black
and white um
in order to get about the people to
listen
uh and and reach their hearts and minds
in that situation
you had to at least
push the the terrorists to a draw in a
lot of parallels here in northern
ireland
um because as long as i mean these ki
their killers uh leave aside their
ideology and as long as they think
they're winning um
they won't bother to listen so but we
certainly
should have done much much more on
hearts and minds
jack straw thank you very much for your
time this morning
if you don't follow politics daily it
can be hard to make sense of what our
two major parties are up to
there's an awful lot of political
cross-dressing going on the tories are
raising taxes to pay for social care on
the other hand this week labor voted
against an extra 36 billion pounds of
funding
for the nhs which they created maybe
there's an explanation let's see joining
me now is the shadow health secretary
jonathan ashworth um
before we get into that john that's
worth we see this morning that uh your
leader plans to publish a 14 000 word
essay which will tell us who he is what
he's about and what labour wants
wouldn't it be just simpler just to say
we're for
higher taxes or we are for
uh a different way of organizing health
service rather than giving us a lot of
philosophy
well leaders publish essays about their
core beliefs all the time it's not
unusual for a political leader to write
an essay for a think tank which is
associated with their party i i think
the broader point here and i want to put
this in the broader context is that look
i don't accept the premise of your
opening remarks i don't accept that a
government imposing a punishing unfair
tax rise on working people
who are who are they also clobbering
with council attack rises we're freezing
freezing their personal allowance and a
lot of them will lose 20 pounds a week
in the universal credit is somehow a
left-wing government and actually the
vote in parliament last week and the
vote in parliament coming up this week
is whether we support that tax rise it's
not a vote on the funding allocations
for the national health service of
course the labour party is always going
to want to see more money going into the
health service but our problem with what
has been announced this week is that it
is a punishing unfair tax rise that
won't deliver the health care that is
needed we won't see people treated
within 18 weeks again like they were
under the last labor government and it
certainly doesn't fix
social care the cap yes it limits the
liabilities that some people will pay
out but only benefits one in seven
people what about the other six in seven
who see no benefit you'll still have to
pay top-up charges and fees so you're
still at risk of losing your house so it
fails on its own terms in the small
print it suggests that because of the
way the financing works council uh
council tax will go up our care homes
will go bust and there will still be
thousands upon thousands of people in
this country who don't get access to the
social care they need so i'm afraid i
gently and politely disagree with the
way in which you frame this okay um i've
allowed you to explain at length why you
think the government's wrong and i hope
that we've dealt with that point now
because i really want to talk about what
labour actually thinks
about some practical things
as well as some
broader political questions um first of
all are you going to go along with the
government's uh
likely decision to end the need for pcr
tests after travel uh if that's what
they decide to do so the health
secretary seemed to suggest uh earlier
on
well we'll
we'll have to see what the proposal is
when it comes before parliament we've
had some briefing into the newspapers
today that certain elements of the
coronavirus act will be taken off the
statute book
at first sight based on the briefing the
clauses which are going to be taken
after of the statute book that looks
like a reasonable approach to me but
obviously we'll want to study the detail
when it comes to parliament because
there have been huge concerns about the
way in which that the coronavirus act
has been uh misused by the authorities
and ridiculous fines have been imposed
on people when they've been you know
sitting on park benches and so on that's
not what this legislation was aimed at
but obviously we'll want to study the
detail we can't just go off what we've
what has been briefed into sunday
newspapers because we want to take we'll
want to take a considered choice in the
round all right well you're you're open
to it okay let's talk about what labour
would do in relation to social care and
you've said
already we don't need to go back over
the tory proposals and all of that um
andy burnham your labour colleague wrote
in the newspaper this week my advice to
my party would be not to leave it too
long before presenting
a better uh proposal criticism of the
tory plan alone
won't cut through unless we say what we
would do and he proposes what he calls
labour's opportunity to end this
injustice which is creation of a
national care service
ask all old older people to contribute
whether they need care or not and
what he has also said is that we might
take a labor government should take a
chunk of
someone's property if necessary are you
up for all that
well let me tell you what our
alternative approach is to social care
first of all we need to expand access to
care and we need to expand eligibility
for accessing that care so we can
deliver the tailored personalized care
for people in their home so they can
stay in their home longer and not be
forced into a home at the moment 3000
people a day are turned down for care
you'll have people watching the program
this morning trevor whose parents
perhaps have got dementia and they are
battling with a complex system day in
day out just to get some basic care for
their parents and they get turned down i
i i don't really ruin john
i don't want to be rude no but you're
what you're telling me is what's wrong
and what you wouldn't do
i've put to you what andy burnham has an
opponent and i really just would like
you to say
i think that's a good idea or i don't
know no or i think it's a bad idea no no
well
i am telling you what our care service
will look like because
if you stop interrupting me i will tell
you well if you tell me
okay well you've just interrupted me
again trevor so if you expand
eligibility with a national framework
for expanding eligibility which is what
we want to see more people will access
care in their home and will not need to
go into a care home or go into a or be
delayed in hospital in a bed and not
able to get care out in the community
out in the community if you do that you
actually save money the ippr for example
has suggested you could save two and a
half billion pounds so there's a two and
a half billion pound saving that we will
reallocate to the front line of social
care secondly you need to raise
standards and quality in care 15 of care
services are rated inadequate the way in
which you raise standards and move away
from these dehumanizing 15-minute visits
where you have to make a choice between
having a warm bath or having a warm meal
or you're put to bed at early evening
not because you want to but because the
system tells you you have to go to bed
we want to end all that by investing in
staff so what we'll do is we'll pay the
staff a real living wage lots of the
staff get less than the minimum wage at
the moment we'll get rid of these zero
hours contracts that a quarter of the
staff are on and will invest in their
training
thirdly there's a number of carers in
this country who get no support
whatsoever we'll give them proper
respite support and fourthly we'll have
a plan for adults with disabilities
particularly adults with learning
disabilities and autism who are
currently today around two thousand of
them
glockens up in hospitals sometimes in
the most
inhumane conditions like
victorian asylum we are going to end
that as well
may i ask you a question proposals on
social care
of course may i ask you a question now
please
you've now given me a four-point program
uh part of which is to raise you think
two and a half billion
victories plan this week is raising 12
billion
where's your nine and a half billion
coming from
yeah
i'm telling you because we've got a
reform program we can release savings
but there are otherwise we can really
other ways we can really save things
nine and a half one of those adults
every one of those adults in an
inpatient care unit with autism of
learning disabilities costs in the
region of two hundred thousand pounds if
we looked after those people in the
community it wouldn't be costing two
hundred thousand pounds per person
you're looking in the region of thirty
odd thousand pounds there's a saving
secondly the way in which we fund social
care in this country is now through
seven different funding streams and it
is delivered through different
mechanisms better care funds continuing
healthcare by bringing health and care
more closely aligned together so the nhs
and local authorities are planning care
in local areas you sweep away
bureaucracy and you can deliver market
and that's really important particularly
for people with dementia who are
currently bounced around the system and
don't get the care that they need so by
reforming care you can actually release
money to the front line
johnsworth thank you very much indeed
[Music]
now party conference season is with us
once again
but it's not the fun type at least not
in scotland where snp delegates will
only meet online one thing never changes
though this autumn's scottish national
party conference is likely to be
dominated by a renewed push for a vote
on independence for scotland
well it would be easy to forget that for
nearly 15 years the snp has actually led
scotland's government they're
responsible for tackling covid and they
should be preparing to host the historic
cop 26 climate conference in glasgow in
just a few weeks time so joining me now
from glasgow is the leader of the snp
and first minister nicolas sturgeon good
morning first minister
good morning
now in the program for government you
delivered to the scottish parliament
this week which i suppose for our
international viewers might best be
described as
a queen's speech for scotland you are
clear that kovid's your number one
priority
numbers are spiking is scotland in
danger of a further lockdown
no not at the moment i think any
responsible leader in the face of this
virus has to keep options open and be
careful not to rule anything out we have
seen a spiking case over the past few
weeks if you go back over the summer we
spiked above uk levels at the start of
july we then came down to some of the
lowest levels in the uk and as our
schools went back we saw cases increase
again we think we're seeing that spikes
start to level off and stabilize the
rate of increase has slowed down it's
what we're saying to people right now is
that in order to drive infections down
further which we really need to do
it's vital to comply with all of the
basic mitigations that we still have in
place in scotland for example it's still
a legal requirement in certain settings
to wear face coverings we're encouraging
continued good hand hygiene good
ventilation um and of course although
it's not the law anymore asking people
to think about distance from people in
other households and thinking about
their overall number of contacts so good
sensible at compliance with mitigations
is what we think is appropriate right
now we also this week it got approval
from the scottish parliament for a very
targeted and limited system of vaccine
certification which we think can help us
reduce transmission in some higher risk
settings so at the moment that's our
message we're going into as everybody
across the uk is a very challenging
and difficult winter period so it's
really important that we
keep a very close eye on what is
happening and lastly the overarching
message to anybody who hasn't yet done
so and who is eligible is to get
vaccinated the vaccines continue to be
the single most important thing any of
us can do to keep ourselves safer and to
keep those around us safer
you are very clear
about vaccine certification what uh is
popularly called the vaccine passport
but
some people including experts like steve
reichert the behavioral science
professor in scotland
say that
you should be concerned that the
introduction of certification actually
could put off some of the people that
you've just said you want to uh
take the vaccine
is that not a concern to you
look steve riker who's actually on the
scottish government's advisory body
although he's entirely independent of
course
actually in a very long and very helpful
twitter thread during the week gave a
very balanced account uh set out the
benefits of vaccine certification set
out and that it goes to the point you're
making here the the things we've got to
guard against if it is to work as
intended and also quite frankly set out
some of the downsides
i think in the face of the situation
against it
look people can take unbalanced views i
think is part of a package of measures
it has a part to play what i was going
to say is firstly anybody who thinks
there is one single
magic wand solution to this virus
probably hasn't learned enough over the
past 18 months and and secondly of
course any measure we take has upsides
and it has downsides i mean if you take
lockdown for example very very effective
at
halting or you know significantly
constraining transmission of the virus
but came with enormous costs in terms of
the economy and our overall well-being
as a society so nothing is
straightforward here this is a very
limited scheme it's very similar to what
has been proposed for england as well
and it has a part to play does it will
it
reduce the the likelihood of people who
are not yet vaccinated to come forward i
don't think there's any evidence of that
if you look at
countries like france that's perhaps the
best example we we actually see the
opposite effect so the message is to
everybody who hasn't yet come forward to
take up the vaccine offer please do so
because it protects you and it protects
everybody it doesn't eradicate the risk
of transmission but it reduces the risk
of transmission and crucially it
significantly reduces your risk of
becoming seriously ill if you contract
covert
another big headline from your speech
this week was your proposal for a
national care service in scotland
which would cover all types of needs
including disabled disability and so on
um
are you envisaging that there would be a
spending cap in the way that the prime
minister has proposed for england wales
i think to ask me to address that
question trevor with the greatest
respect there has to first be an
understanding of the completely
different approach we already have in
scotland to the funding of social care
so it's not quite as simple as saying
are we going to replicate
what is happening in england so for
example that wasn't what i was saying
i simply just asked the question
but but for me to answer that question
with a yes or no would belie the the
differences and i'm just not prepared to
do it and so for example what we have in
scotland that doesn't exist in england
is free personal and nursing care so
that means for anybody who needs social
care right now the state already meets a
much higher proportion of the cost of
that
your personal care needs or if you need
specialist nursing care that is met as
well so the funding
landscape is completely different and
the the arguments for a funding cap
south of the border are not really the
same in scotland now is the overall
funding of social care still a key
consideration as we move forward to
national care service absolutely
alongside that commitment to a new
national care service we have a
commitment in scotland to increase
funding for social care over this
parliamentary term by 25
that in a scottish context is equivalent
to about 800 million pounds the national
care service is effectively and i'm
going to oversimplify here obviously but
it's effectively about making sure that
we have consistent and consistently high
standards of care across the country
that there's less variation much greater
consistency and it is also about
enabling a move to supporting a
workforce
so that that workforce is better
rewarded at the national care service
envisages for example national pay
bargaining and a national
wage for social care workers because one
of the the issues not the only one but
one of the many issues in social care is
the under valuing of those who work in
it and there's a bigger issue there
partly because it's a predominantly
female workforce so we our starting
point in scotland is just so radically
and fundamentally different in england
that i would just guard against lifting
what is being proposed for england
whether you agree with that or not and
trying to transplant it into the
scottish context
one thing that
is
clearly
true about scotland is that right now
most of the care provision
is in the hand or it's controlled to a
large extent by local authorities and
scottish local authorities kosland
indeed the uh city council in in glasgow
where you have your own constituency
have said that they are uneasy
about what they see as a centralization
what you've just called consistency but
essentially you are going to take
the uh control of care service away from
local authorities in scotland and
centralize it
so you know to be frank this is one of
the key debates at the heart of this
reform and i suspect in scotland as we
move from
what we've been doing over the past few
months which is consulting into what we
are about to do which is religiously
this is going to be one of the tensions
and one of the issues that we need to
resolve and you find this often running
through policy discussions about this
one person's consistency which is what
i've just said because often uh the
complaints and the concerns that are
raised about social care is that lack of
consistency but one person's greater
consistency and less variability is
another person's centralization so we've
got to make sure we get the balance of
that right and of course uh we'll listen
very carefully to local authorities who
have expressed concerns about that you
know when you're trying to make a big
fundamental change here you know when
the country came out of the second world
war the national health service was
created we're trying to create a
national care service out of the trauma
of covid you know you can't make big
reforms like that without controversial
and difficult issues to try to resolve
but this isn't really a matter of
balance is it at the moment
social care is largely run by the local
authority board you want to take them
into i think they're going to be called
community health and social care board
which will be under the control and
funded by the scottish government and
i'm not making a a a value judgment
about that but that is a change that you
want to make
well look we already have joint
integration boards across different
parts of scotland funding for social
care
comes initially from the scottish
government flows through councils in
terms of the provision we have a mixed
provision of uh state uh through local
authorities voluntary sector and private
private care homes for example are a big
part of our provision so i guess i'm not
trying to shy away from this the point
i'm making is that if you if you take
your starting point which is a you know
i said earlier on the starting points in
scotland are different to elsewhere in
the uk but perhaps one point of
consistency is that the current
arrangements around social care is not
are not as good as they can be or as
good as they should be so if you if you
accept that
and say we want to reform to make it
better you're going to have these
debates but let's have them and out of
those debates let's get a care system uh
that is fit for purpose learns the
lessons of the pandemic and is something
that in years to come we can look back
on with some pride as a good thing that
happened out of this covert crisis uh
there'll be difficult issues in this for
all governments across the uk but i
think it's time to face up to them
you said in your speech that you want to
have a further independence referendum
by 2023 covid permitting can we just
deal with the narrow question
of timing
and covered what does that actually mean
what level of infection or
hospitalization would make a referendum
impossible given that you've just had
elections in scotland in the middle of a
lockdown
well we just had elections and of course
and just before i i i
so that i don't miss this point the snp
won that election on a commitment to an
independence referendum with a historic
share of the voter constituency share of
the vote was higher than any party has
achieved in the entire lifetime of the
scottish parliament so it's probably a
point
of context that might be important for
our discussion okay fair enough but what
would stop you having the referendum
what what about kobe would stop you
having a referendum
if you can let me i'm going to try and
address your question that it's uh and
i'll try to do it as fully as possible
you've made the comparison with the
election this is not just about safety
of polling stations it's about making
sure that as the country faces a big
important decision about its future it's
able to focus on that properly and that
it doesn't have looming over that a
covert crisis so right now you started
this interview rightly
about talking about the recent spiking
cases in scotland putting enormous
pressure on our national health service
leading me as the first minister to
continue to advise people to take great
care about their interactions i don't
think that kind of situation it would be
the best backdrop to the country
considering and making a decision on its
future i'm not going to set a precise
level of infections but you would want
to see
the the covert situation under control
the pressure on our national health
service significantly lower than it is
right now a sense that we weren't still
in the acute phase of this crisis but
also crucially and i think this is
crucial
a sort of overall environment in the
country where people are not in their
day-to-day lives being asked to
even if not comply with legal
restrictions still limit or restrict
their own day-to-day behavior ultimately
of course as with many things in the
life of governments it will be a matter
of judgment and it's important that i
get that judgment right because i'm very
very serious and have been for 18 months
when i say
the biggest responsibility the most
serious responsibility on my shoulders
is steering the country through the
biggest health crisis in a century
first minister you know me well enough
to know that this is not the sort of
thing that would cross my mind but there
are some
nasty cynical people who would say that
the judgment you really want to make
is when will it be more likely that you
get the answer yes from a referendum
because right now the polls don't tell
you yes we want a referendum or indeed
if there were one that you would
definitely win and that really when you
say
code committing permitting what you
really mean is when it's politically
advantageous to me nicholas sturgeon
it wouldn't i think it's right for the
country look i'm not going to sit here
as as a politician and say that in any
decision i mean we have fixed term
parliaments in scotland so it doesn't
arise and for the time being there are
fixed ten parliaments in the uk but when
that wasn't the case prime ministers of
course used to make judgments on when
they would call a general election based
on when they think they could best when
any politician is going to factor those
kind of judgments into those decisions
and i'm not going to sit here and
pretend otherwise of course some polls
right now do suggest that yes would win
others suggest that yes is slightly
behind i i i'm very confident that when
this question is next put people in
scotland will vote yes and and one of
those reasons is that we have seen that
all of the things that were said to
scotland by the no campaign in the
referendum in 2014 not least that being
independent would see us lose our
european union membership have turned
out to be false so
i'm confident about that but my primary
uh consideration and the two are not
completely divorced from each other my
primary consideration is to do what's
right for the country when is it right i
think it's right that the country gets
to choose its future there are big
decisions that are falling to be made by
governments everywhere as we emerge from
this pandemic who do we want taking
these decisions democratically elected
governments here in scotland guided by
the values of the scottish people or
governments like boris johnson's in
westminster that we don't vote for so
that's the choice and we should make get
to make that choice when the time is
right for the country to do so
well let's talk about the values of
scottish people and what a an
independent scottish government would
look like um
i've seen the the video that uh your
parties put out
ahead of the cop 26 conference
proclaiming that scotland is ready for
net zero does that
mean closing down oil production in due
course
we're in a transition away from fossil
fuels so oil and gas production is not
going to last forever the question is
the pace at which we do that i think
we've got to see that pace
accelerate i think there are big
questions over whether we should
continue with new exploration
in the north sea um and the other
question is how just is that transition
because what we don't want to do is
repeat the mistakes of at the the
deindustrialization that was underway
and that we had the legacy of when i was
growing up where individuals and
communities were just thrown onto the
scrap heap so it's about the pace and
the justice of that transition we are
already in that transition and we've got
to make sure that it happens at a pace
that has is consistent with our net zero
ambitions we have a target in scotland
to reach net zero by 20 45 but actually
we've got an even more stretching target
which is a 75 reduction in emissions by
2030. so there are big big challenges
for scotland here but there are big
challenges
for countries across the world glasgow
is about to host cop and this is
possibly the last chance the world has
to
do what is required to meet the paris
agreement of limiting temperature rises
to 1.5 degrees and we've got to get a
glasgow agreement that allows this
generation of leaders to look the next
generation in the eye
you just made a very important point
which is that
uh you've got to judge the pace but what
you don't want to do
is to create more production now
does that mean that you have decided
that the campbell oil field uh which i
think is east of the shetland which uh
is has where there's uh oil companies
have applied for a license to drill but
you've decided
that you oppose the exploitation of that
field
so again let me address this and i've
set out my position clearly firstly can
i just factually connect uh your
introduction to that question uh the
developers of campbell have a license
they've had that license for i think 20
years what they need to now do is get
permission to start
exploration and production so the
license is there which is part of the
the complication of forgiveness
i think that there has to now be a
process of reassessing that now what i
was going to say is it's not my decision
that's a reserved matter i've asked the
prime minister
not to simply uh go ahead and grant the
permission uh to go ahead with
production as a matter of course that
the license should be reassessed against
the same kind of climate requirements as
new licenses are going to be assessed
now
there are issues here that have to be
considered the pace of the move away
from fossil fuels
but in a way that a doesn't throw people
on the scrap heap but doesn't
inadvertently reduce that sorry increase
our reliance on imported oil and gas
you're asking me to you're about to ask
me to simplify this
your green partners in government are
pretty clear they think you shouldn't
and i'm asking you if you'd had your
brothers would you not have i would that
for oilfield exploited
i i would i wouldn't give the go-ahead
without a fundamental reassessment of
the license and that reassessment the
license exists so you have to do that
reassessment so i wouldn't give the go
ahead without that reassessment to
enable that to be
done against the requirements of climate
change so that there is that rigorous
assessment of whether going ahead with
new exploration which i think many
people and increasing numbers of people
question whether that is consistent with
our climate change targets uh so that
assessment in my view should happen
let me just
quickly take you to a couple of um
rather controversial issues i think that
your government's um addressed um you've
issued guidance on racism to schools
which advises teachers to take a test to
measure their white privilege um have
you taken that test first minister
um i i'd sorry i i haven't i'm happy to
do so um
but you know if you want to
give me more detail of that i will
certainly consider it but i'm not
entirely off the top of my head sure
what you're you're referring to well it
it is a test which says uh
because of who you are and how you're
born
you have privilege in your case
which i in my case do not have and the
advice that your department of education
has given is that schools should give
the teachers should take this test to
demonstrate that they because they're
white have this advantage and i think
it'd be rather good i mean um why don't
we do a deal that the scottish cabin the
scottish government cabinet takes the
white privilege test and one of your you
or one of your colleagues comes back on
and tells us what the results are
i'm happy to i think these things are
really important i don't have the
particular guidance in front of me i'm
not trying to to dodge your question i
did an interview with uh one of your
competitor channels on friday about many
of these issues and and as we consider
all of these issues people like me you
know white people have to constantly
remind ourselves that we have privileges
that the others don't have so i'm
perfectly happy to go away look at the
particular guidance and uh if there are
things that my cabinet should do to make
sure that what we're asking others to do
are things we're prepared to do
ourselves i'm happy to do that that's a
date very last very simple
straightforward question
a lot of work
on the gender uh reassignment issue
do you agree with the most famous
scottish based writer jk rowling
that
there is a biological basis to sex and
that you for example are
a woman not a person with a womb but a
woman
i am a woman and yes i do think there is
a a biological
aspect to sex and i'm not going to
simplify this by sort of saying do i
agree or disagree with jk rowling
there's many things i agree with her on
i'm sure on some of the nuances of this
we might take a different opinion but
let me you know address directly the
issue of the gender recognition reform
bill something that's happened already
in many other countries ireland included
this is about making it easier for trans
people we can go through this process
already but it's about making it less
degrading and traumatic for trans people
to legally change gender it does not in
any way shape or form remove the legal
protections that women have and that's
important to me as a feminist but trans
people are amongst the most stigmatized
minorities in our society and we should
try to reduce that if we can but also
there are real threats to women
across the world right now from abusive
men predatory men misogyny sexism you
know places like texas trying to reduce
the right to abortion let's focus on the
real threats to women's safety rather
than
things that might be perceived threads
but in reality in my view are not right
first minister much appreciated thank
you very much
thank you that's it from us for this
week but stay with us now for the take
with sky's deputy political editor sam
coats
[Music]
you